in this corner of Lithuania they know
their enemy well on the other side of
this border fence the Russian territory
of cliningrad
highly sensitive were only allowed this
close with an official escort
the Russian border post sits at the
Western end of the savalki gap an area
some say has the potential to be one of
the most dangerous places on Earth so
you can see the Russian territory in the
background but on the map I can show you
why this area is sometimes called NATO's
Achilles heel and that's because this is
the savalki Gap at one end we've got
Russian territory at the other we've got
Belarus where Russian troops are posted
and the theory is if President Putin
wanted to escalate this war further he
could essentially send troops from both
East and West cutting off the Baltic
States from the rest of NATO
while there's no sign of panic in the
Sleepy Border Town of vishtitus there's
also no forgetting Russia houses troops
and likely nuclear weapons next door we
hear our helicopters also maybe the
tanks shooting former military man
villius is now the town's doctor
we are afraid because if the Ukraine
Falls we have a big problem why because
the Russians will come also to you yes
to us from kaliningrad also from Belarus
but some people die prepared to to live
Lithuania to the Poland
Lithuania is a NATO member but the war
in Ukraine's put people on edge
volunteer militias have seen a surge in
applicants willing to defend their
country
mindorgas is training to fight Russians
in Ukraine for the second time this year
he's lived under Soviet occupation never
again
the Russians won't come back here he
tells me I will be one of those who will
not let them come back
but at the far end of the savalki Gap
there's another potential danger zone
Russian troops currently stationed over
the fence in Belarus could quickly cross
this border if Putin ever decided to
attack so welcome Gap is a critical
point while the government says there's
no suggestion of invasion now the risk
remain so we must be prepared all the
time in the short term would say risk
risk and Russian capabilities are a bit
lower but the risk of escalation is
higher and that's why we have to prepare
it every moment for for something to
happen
and so Lithuania remains poised watching
its borders reinforcing its defenses
prepared to respond with the full force
of NATO if that day ever comes Siobhan
Robbins Sky News Lithuania